as Biden spent the week embarrassing
himself and the U.S in Ireland while
China's dangerous Coalition grew even
larger now even fake news CNN they are
raising the alarm about the number of
world leaders now rushing to meet with
President XI of China so let me be very
clear
these countries have made a deliberate
calculated decision to side with China
in other words they're betting on China
being the dominant world leader in the
world and you know what that's not good
for us because it's always been the
United States that they look to they are
seeing nothing but weakness under Joe
Biden and failed leadership under Joe
Biden and under President Trump they saw
a strong leadership that's why we saw a
coalition that was built that I didn't
think we'd ever see in our lifetime that
included the United States Israel Saudi
Arabia the UAE Jordan Bahrain
and Egypt they all bet on the U.S When
Donald Trump was president that
Coalition was built by Donald Trump and
it is now crumbling day by day right
before our eyes now they're betting on
China they don't want to be on the wrong
side in terms of what country ultimately
wins out and is the world's most
dominant superpower now last month China
brokered a deal between the Saudis and
the Iranians I never thought I'd see
that in my lifetime Sunni Shia nope they
hated each other many are speculating it
will soon now throw its weight into a
deal between Saudi Arabia and Syria that
we hear is next meanwhile according to
the leaked documents the UAE and Russia
they have reportedly deepened their ties
while Egypt which by the way we give
billions of dollars to allegedly plan to
secretly send thousands of rockets to
Russia amid their war with Ukraine in
other words they are choosing the other
side so even our allies are now
abandoning Joe Biden and betting against
America look look at what happened this
week with the French President macron
the leader of our oldest Ally visiting
China last week sucking up to and
kissing the ass of President XI in China
and by the way throwing the U.S under
the bus over the issue of Taiwan before
urging Europe to move away from their
dependency on the U.S dollar the world's
currency now despite some backlash over
for his outlandish comments macron he's
even standing by his remarks well
tonight I have a message for president
macron you are setting a dangerous
precedent you are damaging ties with the
country that had bailed you out time and
time again throughout history and if
that's your position maybe it's time to
reinstate tariffs on let's say how about
French wine and champagne massive Terror
Earth's psycho 25 30 percent or how
about we stop funding the war on your
continent in Europe the war in Ukraine
until the rest of Europe like the French
until you step up and you pay your fair
share or better yet well Europe is your
problem it's not our problem anymore how
would you like that foreign policy from
America now unfortunately this does not
stop with macron now today Brazil's
president meeting with President XI in
China everyone's going to China to kiss
president xi's ring while Germany's
foreign minister met with her Chinese
counterpart hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else